hello welcome to this symposium by
Hillsdale College on the pressing topic
of the day the corona virus and I've got
three panelists here with me and they're
colleagues and friends of mine they're
all from the politics department and
Kevin Porteous here is PhD University of
Dallas and Adam Carrington as a PhD
Baylor and Tom West is a PhD Claremont
Graduate School back when it was called
the school as it was when I got mine
there and we haven't talked much about
this I hear a little bit of what they
think I'll open with one quick point and
that is I was talking this afternoon
with my friend Hugh Hewitt is of course
up to all kinds of mischief and I made a
point to him that struck him so I'll
make it to you this is like war in some
respects but there's two things you
should think about that and one is
Churchill cautioned constantly against
treating anything in domestic policy
like a war because any serious war
suspends the liberal society and you
can't be having that he wrote that in
1936 in a in a reaction to Franklin
Roosevelt's war on poverty first one
proclaimed the second point is it's not
very honorable if you're fighting in a
war to just be confined to your home in
a war there's stuff for people to do
they can make a contribution they can
feel part of it so this has those two
aspects and that church will always
thought if you get in a big war first of
all don't get in one second of all get
it over as fast as you can well surely
in this case we need to get this over as
fast as we can that's my comment and
Kevin yes thank you dr. iron I've been
asked to talk specifically about
coronavirus as a kind of war we are
being told this is a war our own
governor
got on television recently and said that
this is like world war two and that we
need to treat it as such and I just like
to talk about a couple of problems or
difficulties which doctor aren't
introduced but also to to expand on
those a little bit the first problem is
that Wars traditionally of course lead
to expansion of power now the the
traditional American Way of war was to
build up the government to win the war
and then dismantle it so that during the
American Civil War within a few years
after the end of the war about all that
was left was veterans pensions in the
Freedmen's Bureau most of the
infrastructure that had been built up to
win the war had been dismantled after
the First World War progressives were
forced to watch in a kind of horrors
Republicans in the 1920s under Harding
and Coolidge dismantled much of the
administrative apparatus that had been
built up during the Wilson
administration to win the war they'd
done all kinds of things they'd ceased
control of industries they had built
entire new administrative agencies and
there were many that were hopeful that
this kind of national control over the
economy and over the life of the
citizenry would continue after the war
and and that was not to be the new
American Way of war beginning with the
Second World War is that we we build up
additional government infrastructure to
win the war and then that infrastructure
never goes away
and this as I said began with World War
two and we're still left with things
some of which are very ordinary like tax
free employer sponsored health insurance
and paycheck deductions as legacies of
the growth of the state not to mention
much more major much more major
increases in the size of the state and
and each one layers on top of the last
so that every time we have a new crisis
we build up additional infrastructure
and that infrastructure remains we
should never let a good crisis go to
waste
the second there is over the course of
the 20th century there's a change in the
nature of the way we understand war
particularly as we move away from the
traditional meaning of war as armed
combat against a foe
another another nation as it were and
that was the old understanding Wars and
the traditional sense were waged against
well-defined foes the Confederacy Kaiser
bill the Nazis whoever the case may be
and the objective to be achieved was
reasonably concrete defeat the enemy's
armies in the field force the
capitulation of the armies and the
government and they did require in many
cases massive national mobilization but
only for a relatively short period of
time now that's changed we have a we
have a new understanding in the Great
Depression FDR cast the depression as a
war and in his first inaugural address
demanded wartime powers in order to
solve the crisis now the difficulty of
course is that this is not actually a
war the the enemy is an economic crisis
in the fear that it bred and the
Constitution treats war an economic
crisis differently now
the Great Depression was still somewhat
limited in that we knew that the
Depression was an extraordinary
situation and we knew what normal looked
like employment prosperity etc but the
solution that Roosevelt employed was a
permanent transformation of the regime
in Kennedy in his first inaugural
address talking about the Cold War was
unable to clearly define the nature of
the enemy and the nature of the
objectives so that he declared that this
was a struggle against the common
enemies of man tyranny poverty disease
and war itself Lyndon Johnson in his war
on poverty literally declared war on
what had previously been understood as
an immutable part of the human condition
and victory was defined as the
eradication of poverty but one must ask
what constitutes the eradication of
poverty Reagan in the war on drugs
George W Bush on the war on terror Bush
wouldn't even define the precise nature
of the enemy and it looks very much if
we went back in time like FDR's freedom
from fear what does victory look like
how do we achieve an end to terror
the mission morphed from Chile
killing jihadis too regime building all
over the world and what did we get
perpetual war in order to transform
regimes abroad and many of the elements
of a police state here at home the war
on coronavirus is shaping up to look
like one of these modern Wars massive
intrusion of government into our lives
economic shutdowns violations of
constitutional and natural rights
medical martial law but also mission
creep and ill-defined goals what began
as 15 days to flatten the curve is now
if it even saves one life or until
there's a vaccine or until there are no
more outbreaks but what's an outbreak
how many people is an outbreak these are
not rational ways to make policy now in
a sense that's that's desirable our
politicians kind of like that because on
the one hand it means that if they don't
set goals concrete objectives they can't
be criticized for the failure to achieve
them
and on the other hand it means that that
those that want to can extend their
authoritarian regimes indefinitely so it
suggests that there are massive problems
with trying to think of something that's
not a war as a war and we need to be
clear about things like objectives and
and what the purpose of this is and
rational relationship between the
objective and the goals to be achieved
thank you thank you yeah thank you and
we are speaking together today about
coronavirus and the constitution in
other words measuring the response to
the circumstance by the standard of our
governing document however there has not
been an American response to the
coronavirus I would say there have been
responses I say that because states have
taken the lead regarding most of the
actions addressing its spread and those
responses have taken a variety of
courses regarding as dr. Porteous was
saying the status of schools I would add
restaurants defining workers as
essential or non-essential permitting
gatherings of a certain size and so on
and in assessing state responses
constitutionally some
employed the term police powers to
describe the authority they've exercised
and I've been asked and I will be
talking a bit about what what these
powers are they're not a normal phrase
within our commonplace discussions and
how they relate to our theory of
constitutional government and the
circumstances at least similar to our
own and to understand police power we
have to consider more fundamental
questions both the divided powers and
the United purpose of our government I
begin with the divided powers America
does not have one ruling body or even
one government we the people ordained
and established a constitution
organizing political power along two
lines the first that I won't talk as
much about right now is the separation
of powers whereby we divided our
national governments Authority into
distinct branches according to
legislative executive and judicial
functions the second was federalism the
division of political power between one
national versus many state governments
defining police powers begins with this
latter constitutional structure and
Federalist 45 I think helps us to
understand better the Constitution's
federalism it makes distinct assumptions
regarding national as opposed to state
governments oprius they're said that
quote the powers delegated by the
proposed Constitution to the federal
government are few and defined those
which are to remain and the state
governments are numerous and indefinite
we see this assumption made in the tenth
in them as well where it declares that
quote the powers not delegated to the
United States by the Constitution nor
prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the States respectively or
the people in other words the
Constitution gives the national
governments power by positive
declaration it assigns the state
governments their authority by
permission they or the people possess
anything not otherwise allotted or
prohibited many have summarized these
reserved or permitted powers as the
police power and I would say that in
American history some leave it there the
states can do anything they wish so long
as no explicit limit or
their allocation exists in the
Constitution's text but I think this
understanding is insufficient his
insufficiency stems from not addressing
what unifies our various governments
well differing in allotment of powers
they share a common purpose this purpose
we find summarized in the Declaration of
Independence as I'm sure you're aware
when it says that governments exist to
put secure the inalienable rights of
human beings including life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness the national
government does so and it's
constitutionally granted sphere the
states do and there's regarding this
united but divided the United purpose
but divided powers
I think Federalist 45 again articulates
it nicely
Publius argued that the national
government quote will be exercised
principally on external objects as war
peace negotiation in foreign commerce
these areas these concerns involve the
protection of Rights
these also comprise issues that we hold
in common as a nation and we can see
possibly response regarding kovat 19
that may fall under its sphere but the
same essay then argues that quote the
powers reserved to the several states
will extend to all the objects which in
the ordinary course of affairs concern
the lives liberties and properties of
the people and the internal order
improvement and prosperity of the state
here we see that the states not only
protect individual rights they form the
ordinary normal means for that task at
least most of the instances where we
need our rights secured is left to the
states to do and to dig a little deeper
into how this has been understood I want
to turn to the Supreme Court because
it's I think spent the most time of the
institution's developing and trying to
articulate this principle over the
course of two centuries in fact it is
developed a shorthand almost formulaic
in its description
regarding what state police power seeks
to do this shorthand typically involves
protections for the health safety good
order even the morals of the people and
I would argue that these categories
rightly understood involve the
protection of the rights discussed
before for our purposes the first to
health and safety required greatest the
greater
focus health and safety connect to the
right-to-life infringing either can
result in death but I would also point
out that attacks on both threaten our
liberty as well dissuading if not
outright denying us free action we can
see a host of examples of state
regulations grounded in protecting our
health and our safety laws requiring
licensing for medical doctors for
instance speed limits drunk driving laws
even requirements for a driver's license
itself all come under attempts to
protect the safety of those on the road
these regulations do have a limit though
government exists to protect natural
rights that it can be a view and abuser
of those rights to Federalist 251 state
stated this well noting the government
exists because men are not angels and
limits on government exists because men
not angels administer it thus claims to
health and safety void of substance our
oppression not protection and I'd say
here is with federalism both the powers
and restraints of state police powers
unify under the goal of rights
protection during normal times and I was
thinking of this when when dr. Porteous
was was talking we get a feel for where
the lines exist between rights
protecting police regulations and rights
oppressing ones these times we here are
not normal in emergencies I would say
the goal remains the same but the liens
can change a good example from the
Supreme Court comes in the 1905 case of
Jacobson V Massachusetts that's been
coming up a lot lately
Massachusetts faced a smallpox outbreak
and the state authorized localities to
require vaccinations among the people
one resident sued saying this
requirement violated his liberty and
what's interesting is the court affirmed
the right to Liberty saying that the
Liberty secured by the Constitution does
not import an absolute right in each
person to be at all times and in all
circumstances basically to do whatever
he wants instead quote there are
manifold restraints to which every
person is necessarily subject for the
common good in pursuit of this common
good by the government involved he said
they said the police power to the state
which quote
must be held to embrace at least such
reasonable regulations established
directly by legislative enactment
enactment as will protect the public
health and public safety there are those
criteria and the main point of this
restraint had to do with those actions
which they said involved injury that may
be done to others injury meaning private
actions that violated rights and in this
instance the court considered it
legitimate to call a smallpox outbreak
an emergency health and safety
regulations including forced
vaccinations proceeded quote upon the
principle of self-defense of paramount
necessity in other words the argument
was this is an instance of self-defense
for the life of the individuals involved
if not the community itself and taken to
our current situation the claim of
pandemic if true gives significant
regulatory power at the same time this
power isn't unlimited for one health and
safety must be considered together with
other rights including Liberty of
movement and property not leased
property in one's employment to focus on
just one without the other is to sell
short the full purpose of police power
for another and I think this builds on
what dr. Porteous was saying people we
the people must be vigilant in assessing
the original and on glowing reality of
claims to emergency police powers we
need concrete definitions and defense of
the emergency we need clear articulation
of the rights state actions claim to
protect then we should demand
similarly lucid defenses of the
connection between the emergency the
response by the government and the
rights that response secures vagaries in
this instance will not do especially
with so much upheaval already suffered
by so many Americans in some states
exercises of police powers in this time
must have a standard and a judge the
standard the principles and text of the
Constitution the judge the ultimate
source of power we'd the people
hi I'm going to differ somewhat from my
colleague who just spoke dr. Carrington
I believe America's state and local
governments are engaging in an
unprecedented denial of the most
important natural rights of the people
there has been no significant difference
between Republicans and Democrats with
regard to the response to the virus
worst of all there's been almost no
serious resistance to the suspension of
natural and civil rights politicians our
despicable news media and most citizens
have been complicit there's nothing
close to a precedent for all of this in
American history it's one thing to
require a vaccination it's another thing
to confine most of the nation to house
arrest and shutting down half the
economy and yet all of this has been
done not with a bang or even with a
whimper what are our natural rights our
declaration speaks of life liberty the
pursuit of happiness other founding
documents add the right to free exercise
of religion and the right to acquire and
possess property the purpose of
government as the declaration says is to
secure these rights these words are so
familiar that they for most of us
they've been emptied of any real meaning
beyond what we vaguely remember from
high school history courses and the like
we don't any longer have in our guts a
real sense of what they mean and I'll
illustrate that by saying something
briefly about three of our natural
rights Liberty free exercise of religion
and property first the natural right to
Liberty we've been taught to believe
pretty much that there are only two
things that would deprive us of Liberty
bringing back slavery and taking away
the right to vote but Liberty means so
much more for example
take the right of the people peaceably
to assemble affirmed in both the federal
and the Michigan Bill of Rights people
today seem to take that to mean vaguely
the right to participate in public
protests yes that's one meaning of
assemble but not the most important
meaning the right to assemble also
includes the Liberty to get together
with other people
others who might share a common hobby or
you know or a common interest in them in
a book a reading group it means the
right to share Easter dinner with family
and friends the right to play with one's
children in a public park without fear
of being arrested for going outside and
playing and with a child in the put in
the park and the right to get together
with acquaintances in bars and
restaurants sharing hobbies today the
right peaceably to assemble has been
abolished indefinitely
most states have placed everyone under
house arrest with permission to leave
only for government approved purposes to
illustrate how fundamental that natural
right of assembly was thought to be at
the time of the founding when the
Congress debated the first amendment in
1789 Theodore Sedgwick congressmen
criticized the proposed right of
assembly as quote redundant in light of
freedom of speech unquote
he said if people freely converse
together they must assemble for that
purpose it is a self-evident inalienable
right which the people possess it is
certainly a thing that would never be
called into question
it is derogatory to the dignity of the
House of Representatives to descend to
such minutiae unquote it was
inconceivable to Sedgwick and to most
Americans throughout our history that
the liberty of freedom of assembly
getting together in the earth with your
family and friends and whatever you're
doing ordinary innocent things that that
right would be suspended or cancelled
and yet here we are at least for now
that right is gone second freedom of
religion this freedom is better
understood today than the right of
assembly but even that has been
summarily canceled for a large number of
Americans in many states you will be
arrested if you worship together with
others for the first time in American
history for the founders the natural
rights of free exercise of religion was
not just any old right but a natural
right of the highest importance to
Christians and other believers one which
many founders regarded as the highest
purpose of government altogether third
consider the natural rights who acquire
and possess property
our founders spoke of that right
frequently they designed an elaborate
set of laws to support the right to own
property to use one's own property in
whatever non-dangerous terms they
pleased to acquire property by selling
their labor or the product of their
labor in a nationwide free market today
as you know most of America has been
denied the right to acquire and possess
property on the terms they choose
instead any use or sale of property is
presumptively forbidden with some
exceptions reluctantly granted by
government in the case of quote
essential unquote businesses the
deprivation of this right may be viewed
as a necessity by those whose paychecks
are assured those who work for
government those who work for wealthy
nonprofits wealthy universities but for
everyone else the loss of a job means
the loss of income that would otherwise
support themselves and their families
the natural right to acquire property is
not an abstraction in a high school
civics textbook for someone who has lost
his job I hear every day of another
American thrown into fewer hours lower
pay
or laid off including here in Hillsdale
many such cases I hear every day of
businesses shutting down by the
thousands all over America among my
friends and acquaintances and their
relatives the people protesting the
crackdown are people with a real stake
in society as in a job and bills to pay
they are not motivated by esoteric
debates about political philosophy the
rights of man the natural rights they
don't have a walk-in closet full of
moral signifiers that they use to
display their membership in narrow
identity groups they just try to live
their lives as best they can under
conditions set for them those conditions
are becoming untenable now and so they
are making as much noise as they can
about it around the world I'm gonna I'm
gonna quote a political scientist now
who made the following statement which I
don't necessarily endorse around the
world the governmental shutdown of the
economy and society in the effort to
contain the pandemic threatens human
life and liberty and human life he meant
human life because people need to work
you need to produce income to buy the
things they need and if is not ended
soon he continues people will have the
natural right to resist through civil
disobedience or even revolution unquote
let's hope it doesn't come to that
God willing our rulers will wake up in
time to prevent it still when government
undertakes a deliberate policy of
depriving people of their liberties in
the name of public health and depriving
people of their livelihoods in the name
of public health not for a brief moment
but indefinitely what else can one
expect
thank you well thank all three of you
and I have a question for each of you
and I'm gonna go in reverse order so the
initial predictions about this viruses
was that it was going to kill two
million Americans and that doesn't look
like that now it doesn't look like it's
anything near that but what if that were
true how would you go about fighting it
under the principles of freedom Tom you
would okay the first place you're saying
you're saying that the people already
were dying in large numbers is that your
premise mm-hmm in very large numbers
because we don't have that we had never
had that we had predictions we had
models we had studies from organizations
many of which were funded by the Bill
Gates Foundation which is a foundation
who has a private interest in expanding
vaccinations and is in close working in
close relationship with Big Pharma so we
don't have that situation would be like
what the founders would say is that's
something that people in their private
dealings in their private life would
mostly be able to contain or in extreme
cases as Adam rightly pointed out
temporary and very localized confinement
of people who were actually sick or of
people who were in a particular very
small area hot spot that needed to be
dealt with we could do something like
that not an attempt at a very short very
temporary basis should it actually have
come to that which it never did all the
predictions have turned out to be false
with regard to the extent and danger of
the of the virus what about the claim
that the death count is way lower
because we've done this magnificent
lockdown well if you've seen the graphs
put out by our CDC and others the graphs
themselves reveal that the virus was on
the downturn and was already almost
minute was already had already reached
the minimum at the time the the
crackdown occurred the crackdown has
been
useless from the point of view of
stemming the virus according to these
according to the CDC's own information
but is now actually positively harming
human life in America and around the
world yeah you know so Adam the police
power is an old thing right it's a
common law power it is and it's a
general authority - it comes from
England therefore and it's a general
authority to present the health safety
general welfare and morals of the people
and you're saying it's qualified because
this is a country built on the
principles of freedom think about that
you admit that the state can legislate
in an area if it does contribute to
those goals but the limit is in the fact
that it's supposed to be helping us be
free so elaborate that a little bit like
what would be the difference between the
police power in England today versus
here yeah that's a good question and
some of this I'll have to admit my what
I don't know about the history of
England priox sep 4 what connects with
us I will say for one thing the idea of
the sovereignty of Parliament that we've
never recognized our legislative
branches even if they are elected by us
to be in and of themselves sovereign
that we have a more fundamental law and
that under that law is a fundamental
principle of the natural rights of human
beings and by the way actually not just
freedom also life and that's not to say
whether every response to this has been
the correct one I think what that means
is we don't have the power to dictate
justice whether it is a saw a popularly
elected assembly or whether it is a
bureaucrat
and that therefore when we think of
these things when we think of power
power is not the definer of right right
is defined right defines power in some
ways that's the difference between
Douglas and Lincoln on the question of
slavery how one decides that great that
means that and I want to draw that out a
little bit it is certainly true that in
Britain if a parliament passes the law
its sovereign no court can overrule it
Minh we don't have that here you're
saying because it's a fundamental that
the source of the authority of the
government is us and we give it to them
for some purposes and those cannot be
changed whatever the police power may
have said in some other country right
and I would even add why do we have
consent of the governed and it comes
from a deeper principle of the equal
natural rights of individuals and so
therefore I would say even consent to
the governed is limited by why consent
is there in the first place again going
back to Lincoln Douglas says will solve
slavery by voting on it and Lincoln says
why do you vote because no one man can't
rule another without his consent so
therefore one cannot vote to do
something that would undermine the very
reason for voting and I think that is
something to make concrete one has to
ask on every issue related to how states
are responding to this virus
I don't know how many of you watching
have I've been to virtual Church but I
have it it's not quite the same isn't
comment about the state police powers
yeah one of the things that we Americans
tend to forget is every state has its
own constitution and it's just as
binding on the state government as the
federal is on the federal government and
you know whatever powers the state
legislature gives to Gretchen Whitmer
here in Michigan it's still under the
umbrella of the michigan state
constitution and of the 14th amendment
which also protects you know limits what
states can do and so when she suspends
the right of people to go to work and
the right to freedom of assembly the
right to freedom of religion sure she
can cite this and this power that book
got legislature gives her DAP and
declare an emergency that but that that
power the state can't exceed in its law
powers granted under the Constitution it
can't constitutionally make a law that's
unconstitutional and that is in fact the
legal situation that most of these
governors are in around the country
they're in violation of their own
constitutions in I've looked at Michigan
I know many other states have the same
Bills of Rights
a governor New Jersey whoever he is was
asked the question does this order
violate the Bill of Rights of New Jersey
in the federal government and he replied
that's above my pay grade but yes I
think that's the mentality unfortunately
of most American politicians today yeah
and they're they're using authority and
that's where they get it from it's right
before it's over I can't tell everybody
that I've known these guys you know
since before they were born almost a
couple of one times older than me but
I'm gonna get him to say something
optimistic before it's over somebody has
to say something optimistic I will call
the panel of failure the politics
department of Hillsdale College loves
the American Revolution and classic
political philosophy and some modern
political
but that doesn't make them particularly
bright and optimistic about current
affairs okay the police power and what
would you do in this situation what I
think that given the given the extent of
the outbreak as the others on the panel
have said localized containment measures
and you know let's take our own example
here in Michigan where one of the or one
of the worst states in terms of raw
numbers but virtually all of that is in
Metro Detroit so any kind of containment
measures you know large scale
containment measures should be limited
to those areas which are heavily
affected quarantines should be
quarantined of people who are actually
infected are or who are at high risk and
then and then like people who you know
if you're working in one of these wards
in a hospital then you should be
restricted in terms of where you go when
you're off duty but then beyond that
citizens should be trusted to act like
responsible citizens and if they are
high-risk and we know what those
high-risk groups are then they should
stay home and you know I think it's
perfectly legitimate also for things to
happen like what many what stores have
done this under under order in this case
but this was even happening voluntarily
in many cases having you know okay we're
gonna have a special hour in the morning
for people in high-risk groups to come
in and shop in our grocery store so that
they can so that they can get things
without being exposed to the larger
population okay well that's fine but but
much of that almost all of that could be
done voluntarily
yeah and figured out by the people
involved I'm having an email
correspondence with the guy that I don't
always agree with and and
he likes all these shutdowns and I
pointed out to them that my wife who's a
big gardener can buy a garden hose right
now she can't buy seeds and it's spring
and that part is roped off and and the
point is that was decided in the
governor's office and I'm under the
impression that the governor is a human
being and I know that I can't have
meaningful conversations with more than
seven or eight or nine people a day
right so seven or eight or nine people
are making lists of what's essential to
the people of Michigan and you know the
lightwei they say that colleges have to
go to online well we've done that and
we're probably good at it I mean we're
doing this for example and we have these
very motivated students and we have a
culture here that's it's just marvelous
right and they miss each other and they
want to be with each other because it's
just a fact and I don't know if there's
anybody working for the government
anywhere in America who knows this fact
that the great authors on education say
that the conversations among the
students are at least as productive as
their conversations in class and they
befriend themselves and they can talk
and the point is those people it would
be astonishing if somebody in Michigan
government most astonishing of all in
the Michigan Department of Education
actually knew that fact right but
anybody who works in a good college
knows that and that means that it's just
crazy this thing and if it were
necessary first of all they need to be a
demonstration of that and there's not
been that's what I think we need to come
back to school
okay anybody got any questions for
anybody else anything more to say if I
could pick up on one thing you were
saying and I've thought about this the
the separation of powers and it seems
that what's one reason you know Kevin
was saying presidents like to declare
war why is that because that tends to be
the situation where there is an
emergency of that kind that they're most
in power where they get to exercise
their decision their unity and there may
be a place for that even outside of war
in certain circumstances I think there
is actually but as something progresses
that can't become the normal and one
issue that I hope to see more of is
courts and legislatures that bring
judgement and deliberation according to
the founders in stepping in and starting
to say that decisiveness may lack the
wisdom long term to actually even where
there might be legitimate attempts at
safety to to actually do that to
actually distinguish why you can't buy
certain things why does that have
anything to do with public safety and
that's something that I think hopefully
does not get lost in the midst of this
in addition to questions of federalism
you wanted someone to say something
positive I have something positive that
the accomplishing the the goals the
ultimate political goals that I think
many of us hold to which is to say that
the dismantling of the administrative
state the restoration of constitutional
government the realizations of the
principles of the laws of nature and
nature's God all of that requires a
critical mass of public support and at
present that that critical mass does not
exist and in order to obtain that I
think that's going to require
getting the support of people who do not
now support that goal and cannot be
persuaded by ordinary means and I think
the only way that that some of those
people were going to be reached was by
having them be affected by the the
Leviathans state in some tangible way
that that made them aware directly or
that made them feel that there was a
problem and I think there's at least a
possibility and you see this with some
of these protests that are going on I
think there's at least a possibility
that all of this overreach may have
contributed to that in the long term so
that's something to be positive about ok
I agree I like to add that on the on the
positive side optimistic side is that
this country is still governed by
elections ultimately and it's true the
electorate the voters have gone along
with a good deal of what Kevin was just
talking about the consolidation of the
modern state and his dictatorial
tendencies on the other hand when things
get out of control and they begin to
feel the pain of the mismanagement that
we're now currently suffering they will
act you're seeing that in these
demonstrations now city by city around
the country spreading the first
demonstrations people were carefully
socially distancing the six-feet now
they're starting to just come together
and be right together in a big crowd
like you people need to stop this
nonsense we need to go back to work I
was talking to my neighbor yesterday
Wednesday in an illegal conversation
into their living room in which she they
were talking me we're talking to me
about you know this you can't really
have life the right to life isn't really
being preserved when you are in prison
in your own house and not allowed to go
outside life is his activity aristotle's
life is activity and people resent that
and now they're getting angry and
politicians are beginning to notice and
they will begin to notice a great deal
more soon I'm very optimistic that these
policies will
be reversed in the very near future some
places it'll take longer than others but
we're going to be building back up again
it's going to be a long hard slog it's
going to be much harder than people say
than people right now understand we're
gonna have a worldwide depression I
believe but there's one way to stop and
that's to start getting out of it's they
don't if you're in a hole stop digging
so I mentioned that Brian Westbury whom
I had a conversation in this series
yesterday and yeah I mentioned him in
Primus - he's my favorite economist and
he's a very data-driven guy and a very
decent good guy and he says it's going
to take two years to get out of this and
if we do everything right it's going to
take two years to get back where we were
and where we were by the way was it a
great peak I mean unemployment rates
were at historically low levels and they
were reaching especially down into
people who hadn't had jobs for a long
time and that's see you see what a
vindication that is I heard many
conversations I wouldn't say I agreed
with this but I didn't didn't disagree
that said that those people have just
got used to never having a job and
they'll never go to work well it come to
find out human nature is a persistent
thing right they want to work they want
to be responsible for themselves and
just put these numbers together right
the American economy makes produces
about two trillion dollars a month's and
Brian Westbury said that the cost of
this is up to four trillion dollars now
and sure enough what we're doing is
we're taking what the American economy
would produce and borrowing it against
the future so people can live inside
their houses right how long can that go
on I mean six months is a lifetime with
numbers like that and there are people
talking about six months I mean there's
a college in Boston that is announced
that it's not gonna have in-person
classes in the fall well I'm saying that
we're going to have
person classes in the fall because
that's what we do in a hundred and
seventy-five years not in the Civil War
not in the second or First World War
not in the Great Depression was this
campus emptied of students and now it is
it's just indignant making to me
anything else so thank you gentlemen as
you can tell these guys are pretty good